well how do you like the spot they gave
us well you go go try to be funny
following a monkey and Walter Martha the
next awards are for the best achievement
in documentary productions both for
features and for short subjects the
nominations for Best Documentary Feature
a few notes on our food problem
James blue producer journey into self
bill macaw produces the legendary
Champions William Katyn producer are the
voices David H soya producer young
Americans Robert Cohen and Alex brasov
producers award the winner is young
American
tonight in Bangkok in Thailand there are
36 young Americans most of them the cast
of film singing for our friends in
Thailand so it's really to them they
made the picture it's about them that I
wish to thank thank you very much
the nominations for documentary short
subjects are the house that our man
ananda built folly Balamory a producer
the revolving door leo bob her producer
a space to grow
Thomas P Kelly junior producer a way out
of the wilderness Danny wise board
producer y man creates Saul Bass
producer and the winner is why man
creates all box
thank you thank you very much